Okay, let's take these one at a time. We
have two copies of a silent mutation in OCA2. Silent
mutations don't change amino acids. So we aren't going to
expect any change in the overall function of the OCA2
protein. So it would be fully functional. And should
give us the brownest. Which should be a ranking of
one. Two copies of a nonsense mutation in OCA2. Nonsense
mutations are going to make a shortened protein. Probably dysfunctional largely,
meaning it's not going to carry out it's normal function, is
likely to be bluer, but we're not sure if it'll be
the blue list yet, so let's actually take a look
at the last option. One copy of the mutation in the
OCA2 promoter reducing transcription. Well, this doesn't sound as severe,
right? We still have functioning copies of OCA2 But we just
don't have as many of them. So maybe we don't get
as much pigment. This doesn't sound as severe as this one.
So this would be somewhere in the middle and this would be the bluest or three.